من اول ما بدا عرض مسلسل النار بالنار
والجدل مرافقه في كثير من الامور ان كان
بالمشاهد او القصه والسيناريو او حتى
الكلام اللي بيتكلموا فيه بين بعضهم في
المسلسل في العمل بيجسد قصه حي تغيرت
تركيبته السكانيه من بعد الحرب السوريه
ونزوح السوريين واستقرارهم فيه وبيتناول
المشكلات والصراعات اللي بتصير فيه وكان
كاتب العمل رامي كوسا ووضح من خلال
منشورات متعدده على صفحته الشخصيه انه في
تعديلات كثيره على السيناريو والقصه هو مو
عاملها وحقيقه كان في مشاهد عملت جدل اكثر
من غيرها مثل خلع مريم اللي بتقوم بدورها
النجمه كريس بشار خلعها للحجاب علشان تطلع
جواز سفر واوراق جديده ومثل مشهد كمان
الاخذ والرد بين عزيز اللي هو جورج خباز
ومريم اللي هي كريس بشار واللي الناس
شافوا فيه عنصريه او غيره من المشاهد اللي
عملت الجدل وامس كان في مشهد تصدر المنصات
وعمل حاله تفاعل كبيره بين الناس وهو كمان
بين عزيز ومريم والمشهد كان بدا بخناقه
كبيره وضرب وانتهى بدمعه وابتسامه
صفات مريم العزيز قلبت المنصات
وعلى فكره كل الجدل اللي حوالين المسلسل
كان طلع مخرج ومحمد عبد العزيز من ساعات
ورد على بعض الاجزاء المتعلقه فيه فقال
انه مشهد خلع الحجاب ما بيحرض على لبس
الحجاب او خلعوه ابدا وانه التعديلات اللي
كاتب المسلسل بيتكلم عنها تمت على عده
مراحل تحت اشراف الشركه المنتجه للعمل
وبموافقه الكاتب اللي ابدا في بدايه الامر
مرونه كبيره لكن في مرحله ما وصلوا الى
طريق مسدود وانه الفنانين المشاركين في
العمل امثال عابد فهد وكريس بشار وجورج
خباز وطوني عيسى اثر العمل
بملاحظاتهم وان العمل صار في مناخ خيمت
عليه يروح الفريق الواحد
[موسيقى]